- On le répète depuis 30 ans,
aussi bien documenté :
les changements climatiques
vont non seulement transformer
notre planète, mais ils sont
comme on le voit aujourd'hui
même en Australi
Partout sur Terre, dit lerts dr
le climat, l'impact des gaz àef.
En août dernier, le GIEC
annonçait que le mercure
atteindrait 1,5 degré au-dessus
sur Terre en 2030, soit 10 ans
plus tôt que prévu,
Aujourd'hui, on enfonce le clou.
entre aut entre aut entre aut ,
qu'un grand nombre d'espècesmard
se déplacent maintenant
vers le nord à ces eaux.
Que la survie de jusqu'à 14 %
des espèces terrestres est
menacée à court terme
et que 9ctuellement près
de zones cotières à risque
d'être inondées d'ici 2050.
FRANÇOIS GEMENNE,
co-auteu
- Quelles sont les zones du
monde qui vont rester habitables
envisager des déplacements
ou des transferts
de population?
- Le groupe d'expert estime
eaux douces et 8 % des océans
sont prois qu'il
faudrait doubler, voire tripler
ces chiffres pour permettre
Et pour la première fois,
se de dévese de dévese de dévesr
dès maintenant des stratégies
d'adaptation aux extrêmesuuuuuuu
sud d'abord, parce qu'il sont
ipés pour y répondre.
Mais aussi au Nord, parce que
personne n'y échappera.at-
énergie, Greenpeace
- On a trois côtes: Arctique,
Donc, l'augmentation du niveau
de la mer fait qu'on doit
Au niveau des canicules,
évidemment, il faut augmenter
forestier.- Le prochain rapport,
en avril, proposera des
ralentir les émissions
de gaz à effet de serres.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon